[Music]
21 let's do it black d4 okay let's go
let's go kid let's let's go kid
okay no
okay you know what we're going to do
we're going to test our opponent on
a line of the london that i played
against gotta
and it's a line that a lot of people
still don't know
so we start with c5
then we take on d4 and you quickly go
queen b6 the very very tricky line
against
inexperienced london player so he knows
that he goes knight c3
obviously if you know the first thing
about this line
do not take on b2 that leads to a very
theoretical line that's good for white
eric rosen has analyzed that
but
what we do here is we actually go d6 and
the zen behind this line
is that we have essentially lord we have
lured the knight on c3 and london
players
do not like
positioning the knight on c3 most london
players they much prefer for there to be
a pawn on c3 in my experience
watching students play this playing this
myself
you get
you know a lot of london players just
falter really quickly in these types of
structures so the best thing to do
in terms of developing the dark squared
bishop
what should we do with it what seems to
be natural to you guys
definitely fianchetto
because if you play e6 you block the
other bishop and even after you play e6
the bishop has nowhere to go so so here
you definitely want to fianchetto
and then you want to castle and develop
the knights of c6 all the all the normal
moves so i'm going to play them very
quickly
i'm not going to spend too much time
here
okay so there's basically a couple ways
to play this type of position
there's a couple different
viable setups in my
experience
you can now the immediate the immediate
knight c6 is a little bit inaccurate
because it runs into the move d5 and
that sends then it's not a big deal but
allowing d5 with tempo
is unnecessary so i would prefer to
develop the light squared bishop first
now you might where do we develop it
well you can put it on f5 or you can put
it on g4 if you put it on g4
white will probably play h3 we will
trade the bishop for white's knight and
then develop our knight to c6
pressuring d4 but i do not particularly
like to give up the bishop pair in these
types of positions so
and i'll flesh that out a little bit
further after the game so let's go
bishop to f5 instead
and take a sip of my water and pause the
video and if you're just along the show
congratulations you found the move
no but knight h4 is but again a move
like knight h4 you're succumbing to one
move itis
one one vitus has two forms it's when
you make a move because it creates a
threat and when you make a when you're
afraid of a move because that move
carries the threat
okay so so we still
so now after knight c6
d5
we have the additional option of going
knight to b4
which leads to some tactical
complications that i will
flesh out after the game but for now i
will say
that oh wait wait let me calculate that
there there there oh
no let's do it let's do it let's go
knight c6
i i saw an interesting line in case in
case y goes d5 here which is not a given
because again most london players like
they don't necessarily like to make
moves like d5 which are very committal
but he does
and let's go knight before that's the
whole point of putting the bishop on f5
in order to attack c2 and win a tempo
now the move that initially
dissuaded me from playing bishop f5
from playing knight c6 rather is this
move knight f3 to d4
which defends the pawn on c2 and
simultaneously puts pressure on the
bishop on f5 but after knight d4 i
discovered what i think is a good move
so let's see what white does
most players in the 17 1800 ranger
probably go rook b1 to c1
which is incredibly passive and a bad
move
now if i were you i would start thinking
what you would do against the move
knight d4
91 okay close but very passive
let's try to deconstruct this position
logically black has
more act we have more active pieces
but if we if we
waste time or we dilly dally white's
going to play a3 on the next move and
what we want to try to avoid is a
situation where we just have to bring
our knight back to asics that is far
from the end of the world that's okay so
if we can't avoid that situation that's
fine but we should try if possible to
make a move that creates a threat i
might say well what is white's biggest
weakness the white's biggest weakness is
clearly the d5 pawn
can we try to attack it it's not as easy
as it seems because if you play queen a5
which a lot of you are suggesting white
can defend the pawn with his bishop
bishop c4 or bishop f3
and
i don't see exactly what we have
achieved here
i also like the look of knight e4
i really like the look of knight e4
but knight e4 amazingly white can still
go through that's a little bit unlucky
oh we lose a piece there wow
wow there's some crazy lines
no i think i i think the best thing to
do for us is to come to terms with the
fact that we're going to go knight a6
that which is okay
and there's no reason to freak out here
let's just go with c8
let's just cover c8 let's improve our
position
bring our knight back to a6
and then we can redeploy the knight to
c5
and one of the points that i want to
make through the prism of this game is
that
people become super afraid of of moves
like knight a6 when there's no reason to
be afraid we will improve the night
shortly except i also just blundered
upon that's just great i completely
forgot about this pawn i should have
should have put the other rook on ca
that was
a complete
lapse in judgment
yeah for white can simply take the spawn
it's it's really not the end of the
world
it's far from the end of the world to
lose a7 but no reason i should have
given that away
i should have just gone rook fc i i just
forgot that that pawn hangs should have
gone rook fc8 so that the other rook
defends a7
let's see if white takes it we'll
pretend this is a gambit this is a
sacrifice
this is sacrifice
bishop f3 he doesn't take it
but we're in a bit of an awkward spot
here we're in a bit of an awkward spot
because knight c5 runs into b4
i i feel like i've misplayed this
we'll have to look after the game
we need to breathe some new life into
this position
okay let me let me think we can sack the
exchange on c3 that's an interesting
idea but it is very dubious i'm not
sure that we get enough comp
we can play rook c4 maybe
let's go rook c4 let's try to harass him
just just sort of a move that that you
know just trying to get
get stuff going a little bit
annoy him
just gotta play chess here bishop back
to e2 now sacking the exchange actually
is much more appealing and then playing
knight takes d5
i think we're gonna go for it
yeah
and now we sack the exchange
and this
idea
everybody should be familiar with this
is the classic exchange sacrifice on c3
which is
endemic to
like tons of openings mo
probably most commonly sicilian
if you're a sicilian player like you
have to be aware of that c3 sack hikaru
won a game against me
through that sack
um in the us championship it's like
super super i've won games with the
exchange i'll show you both examples and
uh i was told that i have to ask people
to like videos on youtube so i'm gonna
do that
really helps thank you all right moving
on knight takes c3 oh i
probably should have taken e3 yeah no
that was bad i should have taken the e3
pawn
or was it bad hmm
so this is hanging
this is hanging
it looks like i have tactics here but i
don't knight c5 is interesting bishop c5
dc
rookie seven queen eight three position
is okay
let's go knight c5
i'm very concerned about bishop take c5
though
oh i came up with a night
okay this is one of those games where i
am going to have to focus like super
hardcore because this guy's amazing
this guy is amazing
okay what do we take with
should take out the pawn
with the pun thank you seven
what's gonna happen
then i suppose we play bishop to f6 to
chase the rook away
try to get it onto a wow bishop d3 okay
i guess we play rook d8 now
in order to pin the bishop
preparing the move c4
the issue is that white can play queen
e3 and
get out of the pin we'll have to check
this game very carefully with an engine
to see
any blunders that's honestly very sad
that he blundered like this because this
would have been a very interesting end
of the game
queen c1 is just such a dumb move i mean
it puts the queen right on
right just on a golden platter it gives
us the win bishop takes d3 but but again
i think what we are seeing in this speed
run is that when you create
super complicated positions like even
super strong players they make these
blunders all the time
it's a bummer that that white did this
honestly and i will criticize my own
level of play which is not very high
this game so maybe i'll learn something
too we'll we'll delve in with an engine
and we'll see what the proper way of
playing that position is well that's
what you get for playing the london i
guess
so we're just going to go straight into
analysis with an engine
because
i'm very curious as to a couple of
critical moments in that game
the reason i want to use an engine this
game is because i really want to get to
the bottom of how
we should set up our pieces in that line
so people watching on youtube might be
grimacing but
i'm i'm very sparing
in like my choice of using the engine
yeah i guess they're doing a server
restart in 23 minutes so this probably
has to do with that okay so in that case
we'll have to analyze on chess space
so
the engine gives an advantage okay
knight c3 so kamsky kamsky played the
other movie which is knight a3
so this
if you take the pawn then
white wins this is very well known
uh obviously these two positions are the
same so knight c3983 are interchangeable
so this loses
to
yeah this loses
but if we check the the online online
database this position has been played a
ton but people have walked into this
you play knight a6 to defend c7 the move
is a3 and the rook is trapped and the
queen is trapped
knight d5 and look at this
rook b1
queen a2 and rook b3
this is an amazing move
you sack the bishop and then you trap
the queen like this
queen is trapped
really really pretty construction there
so do not take on b2 if you're if you
play this line as you can see the
engine's top choice is like a6
we played d6 okay the engine doesn't
love this
the new stockfish does not love the move
d6 so i guess the most accurate move
here is to play actually
a6 which is a very interesting move
what is the purpose of a6 i think the
purpose of a6 is to prepare queen takes
b2
ah and there's no knight b5 aha
so a6 is cool it covers the b5 square
which prepares queen takes b2 and if
white plays a move like rook b1
then after d5 already black is totally
fine
even more than fine
knight f3
yeah bishop f5 and this is like a super
comfortable london for black
so we can learn that the move is a6
actually okay we played d6 rogue b1
is inaccurate rogue v1 is inaccurate
but who's gonna play a4 like who's gonna
find that move a4
again with the typical idea of expanding
on the queen side
um a4 is a cool move and if black just
continues along the same lines then
white plays a5
again if we take the pawn
oh actually here the situation changes
because the pawn is on a5
so you have to give a bishop check on b5
bishop d7
trade and knight g2 and white's lead in
development
and the super awkward queen position
means that white has huge compensation
for the pawn
so if black plays a5 it weakens the b5
score tremendously remember that when
you do this
you create a massive hole on b5
massive hole on b5 and white can stick a
bishop there
so that's bad
so white played work b1 we play g6 we
develop our pieces
this is all normal
okay bishop f5
is apparently inaccurate
because of h okay
okay it's all right h3 is good knight c6
d5 is best knight before
okay so here there's an insane computer
move which nobody would ever play queen
d2 just leaving the pawn hanging on c2
a queen i mean how do you find such a
move
what is the idea the idea is basically
the following
i can see this from starfish's line
bishop takes c2 rook
bc1 now white is threatening to take on
c2 right
so black has to drop the bishop back
if you play
oh
there's a beautiful idea let me turn off
stockfish for a second
so wait a second let me lock the engine
here
does anybody see what white does after
an 84
does anybody see the best move here or
the best series of moves
wow people
sleeping come on guys
the queen is hanging yeah knight takes
e4 bishop b4
and rook c4
both minor pieces are hanging
and if you play bishop takes f3 white
has inter mezzo rook takes b4 first
attacking the queen and then why wins a
piece
yeah all right let's check the engine
yep that's right that's the line so
knight e4 doesn't work
black has to drop the bishop back to f5
so now i plays a3 and b4
restriction classic idea restricting the
knight on a6
now you might look at this say
why is white better black is up upon and
this is very hard to explain the the way
i would think about it and even i would
have a hard time evaluating this
position
there are several structural problems in
blackboard first of all the knight on a6
is is is totally out of the game
and if you try to bring it back into the
game then you're going to lose your
queen after bishop e3 the queen is
simply trapped
so
okay isa asks a question in that
position would you take the rook and
then take the bishop money too yeah
probably the best that black can do is
this but after rookie one notice that
black is also losing the e7 pawn so
normally this type of position would be
okay but you're also dropping e7 and
then d6
okay wait wait i'll explain
you can't reactivate the knight
and if you play a neutral move like rook
ac8
then
you lose the pawn on a7 you lose the
pawn back
now you might say okay well what if i
play rook fc8 so i don't lose the pawn
well then white still plays bishop e3
and white just accumulates the central
pressure
the underlying problem in black's
position is that we are super cramped
the pawn on d5 is controlling key
central squares and the knight on a6 is
permanently out of the game giving white
excellent compensation for the pawn
white as an advantage not a huge one but
a pretty significant one
why is queen d2 necessary queen e2 just
defends against the threat if you play
the immediate a3 you blunder and
exchange because bishop takes c2 is a
fork
so so queen queen d2 is a prophylactic
move
which takes the sting out of the move
bishop takes c2 it makes sure that that
move does not come with a fork
but knight e1 is completely
understandable the move i was expecting
is knight d4
and here i was planning to play bishop
e4
here i was planning to play bishop e4
but anyways 91 is passive
oh so here the best move was queen a5
but the reason i didn't play it is
because of bishop c4
oh rook ac8 bishop b3
okay and now the exchange sack so i had
the right idea of sacking the exchange
but i didn't find the right moment to do
it
so this is just winning for black just
because white's position is totally
collapsing look at this
just look at look at look at white's
position
and after bishop d2
you go 94
i mean you're just all over him knight
c3 is coming
no this is this is uh this is something
i should have seen
i stopped after queen a5 bishop c4 i
also thought light has bishop f3
but now i realize that that just drops a
pawn on a2
and if white goes rook a1 then you allow
knight takes c3 attacking the queen
so these positions are intensely
complicated we played rook ac one bad
move allowing a3
bishop b3
twin a5
bishop f3
i was more worried about bishop takes a7
but now we actually have b6
i also did not see that
for some reason i thought white plays b4
in this position
oh knight takes before oh
discovered attack on the bishop
discovered attack on the bishop that's
what i didn't see
because i only saw queen takes a3 here
but now white has knight b5 and the
queen is in huge trouble
and not just the queen is in trouble but
the knight on a6 is lost after rook a1
this is what i calculated
but i forgot that we have knight takes
before here attacking the bishop
yeah just so many ideas here that
they're so easy to miss so white plays
bishop f3 which is good
rook c4 is fine bishop e2
and this is correct
so we are actually better according to
the engine here
but knight takes c3 no knight takes c3
is okay wow actually i i didn't play
that badly
it would have been better according to
the engine to take the bishop and really
ruin white structure completely
but we took here we played knight c5
and dc is also fine
wow so i'm actually not worse here
i'm actually not worse in this position
that's interesting we have enough
compensation i was a little bit overly
pessimistic
was a little bit overly pessimistic
according to the engine
queen takes e5 is better
oh and bishop f6 yeah just compensation
and nothing much to say here other than
that black has
insane peace activity in response for
the in return for the exchange
um but
it is sad that white
the white blundered between c1 and
allowed bishop d3 and 92.
in conclusion
we can make a couple of interesting
observations
which is that
okay so bishop f5 is disliked by the
engine
bishop f5 is disliked by the engine the
engine feels that the bishop is
misplaced on f5 the engine wants us to
play a more uh waiting type of move and
wants us to play a6
in order to cover the b5 square
and sort of wait for white to
show their cards
oh and queen back to c7 the engine
actually wants to fee and cattle the
light squid bishop this is interesting i
didn't think about that at all
the engine actually wants us to
fianchetto the bishop do you guys see
that
queen c7 and then b6 and bishop b7
which makes a lot of sense so bishop f5
is inaccurate
h3 and then knight c65 is just better
for white
if he finds queen d2 which is a really
hard move
after knight knight a5 we missed queen
a5 bishop c4 rook ac with the idea of an
exchange sack on c3
and
then
bishop f3 rook c4
yeah bishop b2 back was a mistake
because it takes white's eyes off of the
d3 pawn
and allows the exchange stack on c3 and
this position is just good for black
yeah very interesting game i mean this
kind of analysis is not going to win you
any brilliancy prizes it's not that
interesting
but uh it really
and this is something i think that's
greatly underestimated it is the best
way to learn
how to play complicated positions play a
game like this you spend 30 minutes with
an engine
and by yourself just like looking around
discovering new ideas open i call this
open-ended analysis
right it's just like you're not trying
necessarily to
just understand something specific
you're just trying to like
get a sense of what's going on in a
particular position what the typical
ideas are
which typical mistakes you made
it's not the most interesting activity
but it's incredibly effective incredibly
effective
this is the first time that i exploited
this idea
and it as i mentioned during the game it
came in a night or
which i used to play exclusively
sozen
so i misplayed the opening here
i misplayed the opening but eventually
my opponent misplaces it back and he
plays too slowly roxier okay he won
black to play in this position what did
i do
and it took me a while to decide on this
move i was like am i crazy for wanting
to do this
yeah rox c3 bang
i'd say well
rook takes c3 is usually only good when
white has to play bc
but and that's what my opponent did my
opponent played bc i remember he was
thinking for a long time
and the reason he didn't play queen
takes c3 is probably because i take with
tempo
and look at this knight
look at the bishop just the diagonal
the center control the black has
absolutely worth it even though i think
objectively white is probably better
here and probably the reason why white
is better is because there's this very
nasty idea of white pushing the f-pawn
down to f5 and creating
massive pressure down this diagonal
i don't know what the engine eval is
here my guess would be
0.8 maybe let's see maybe i'm even
overestimating white's position
underestimating my own compensation
it is
drum roll please
it is
this is an exciting moment
yeah i'm right on the money point 0.5
black is not oh it's even equal black is
black is not worse
let's see is rick takes e3 the top
engine move
no it's not it's not the engine just
says black is better if you just play
normally
which is kind of lame queen d7 while
queen d7
oh to prepare a5 to prepare queen side
pressure with a5
so rook c3 is not the top move but it's
not bad
and bc is a really bad move because
oh and i should have taken the knight
but then i found this very nice idea
queen a8
takes takes rook c8
and i just like i didn't play perfectly
but i
i put enough pressure on him to where
eventually i got into this end game and
he blended a fork
oh no he did not blender a fork he gave
me this check
but i outplayed him in this end game
and i was worse for a while actually i'm
still worse if he finds rook b6
but he didn't find it
and he made a really bad move
what is the tangible benefits of
swapping your rook for their nightbot
hunt well it's not a swap it's a
sacrifice
well the tangible benefit is first of
all okay first of all we ruined the
structure
second of all we have ruined white's
pawn center third of all we have gained
for ourselves this long diagonal
which might allow us to build a battery
with the queen coming to a8 and pressure
on g2
so
it's not i i can't just like oh this is
a one thing that we gained or the
sacrifice it's like a it's a sacrifice
that when you gain a couple of different
things that that taken together are
supposed to give you enough compensation
for a very minor sacrifice i mean it's
an exchange for a pawn it's not that big
of a deal
right and your essential control is much
better
no but why can't just trade but it's not
easy for white to trade bishops how how
do you propose that white get
that white trades light squad bishops
here
this structure absolutely matters yeah
the structure matters your white
structure is [ __ ]
so
it definitely matters
and then hikaru beat me with a very
unsound exchange sect
that ended up producing a super strong
psychological effect
so i can show you the hikaru game as
well you can also find it on again
matters channel i think again mata did a
video
on my my game with hikaru
it in my defense this was like my worst
the worst tournament of my life
um
this was
the us championship
2015.
so i was white against the cars around
five
i think i had like one and a half out of
four and i had one out of four so i'm
doing badly but i i had a great
preparation in the dragon which she car
played and i had this like rare line
prepared with h early h4
and i
i i got a huge advantage here
like once i played bishop g5 i'm like
plus minus so high takes like 20 minutes
and he takes on c3
and i could tell that he was like bsing
because like i i knew that this i'm like
literally up in exchange in this end
game
but
practically speaking it's actually very
hard to play this with white
because black gets the sustained queen
side pressure a b
black has better place pieces and c it's
just very hard for white to make any
sort of progress
so i lost this really quickly
i played a3
he goes roxy and i played team b2 he
goes king f8
and at this point i think i took like 30
minutes and i literally could not find a
single plan
i could not find anything that i liked i
should have just played a freaking
normal move like rook he won but i was
getting nervous because i knew that i
was pretty close to actually winning if
i played correctly
and i played this horrendous move 92
have
this is like such a bad tournament i
don't even know what was going through
my mind bishop b5 i had to go back to d4
and of course he doesn't repeat he
improves the position of his bishop
then he starts getting his knight around
to c4
and now i just panicked completely i
went out for another terrible move
we got this position now my bishop is
essentially trapped so i have to go f5
and that weakens my structure even
further
and i mean i just got squashed here
eventually i get gave the exchange back
and and he just won easily i mean this
is just terrible terrible game for for
my on my part but
uh but you you can take a look at the ag
and modder video um
for for more like clear cut analysis but
if you turn on the engine here it's like
plus 1.5 it's almost winning for white
uh so so from a purely like objective
standpoint this exchange tag was on
sound it just shows you that that these
ideas are out there and if you do a good
job of you know discovering them then it
really enriches your play
this is how you get good at positional
chess like
you see an idea like this you file it
away in your mental
rolodex like oh this is interesting next
time you have a position like this you
start considering rick takes c3
you know you're not as afraid of
exchange sacrifices then you spot
another idea
and that's how your play starts to
acquire
that air of erudition because you you
just become aware of all these different
ideas
so try to be my recommendation try to be
a sponge for
thematic ideas and then apply them to
your own games
there's plenty of games where the rook
takes three is the best move yeah for
sure um because i was not invited teddy
all right guys on that note we will end
it's way later than i planned to stream
i have the dentist in four hours and 59
minutes
i'll see you guys later thanks so much
everybody
thank you for hanging out
bye bye everybody
[Music]